más de un millón 351 mil casos de kobe
19 en un día en el planeta
esta cifra arrojada por la oms nunca
antes se había registrado en dos años de
pandemia y refleja la alta incidencia
que está teniendo o micro una variante
mucho más contagiosa que las registradas
anteriormente sin que haya mermado la
temida delta delta en omicron artwin
trets delta yo me con son amenazas
gemelas que están elevando los casos a
cifra récord widget game lo que
nuevamente está provocando picos en las
hospitalizaciones y muertes antes
a miley cansan estoy muy preocupado de
que omicron al ser más transmisible
circula el mismo tiempo que delta ya que
está provocando un tsunami de casos
sliding de tsunami of case es esta ola
de contagios está afectando a todo el
mundo por igual en américa latina países
como argentina y bolivia han registrado
récords de casos en eeuu la realidad no
es mucho mejor ya que se estima que
omicron es la variante dominante pero el
continente más afectado es europa donde
omicron ha emergido poco antes de las
navidades sin embargo aunque los casos
están muy elevados las restricciones han
vuelto de forma parcial y muchos no
creen que la situación sea peor que en
esto no tiene nada que ver con el año
pasado 11 un sequía de casas no
sabemos qué hay casos que están
aumentando pero no nos damos cuenta
tratamos de vivir con normalidad claro
respetando las normas de salud pero esto
no nos impedirá vivir normalmente
esto se puede entender porque omicron a
pesar de ser extremadamente contagiosa
incluso entre gente vacunada
una tasa de mortalidad y hospitalización
menor que las otras variantes